hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
i r bio typer new insights into
microorganism strain and serotyping by
ftir
spectroscopy i am marie stone of labruts
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by brooker to learn more visit
brooker.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
dr marcus myers product manager ir bio
typer and care consumables at brooker
daltonics and dr maria pardos de la
gandara deputy director of the french
national reference center for e coli
shigella and salmonella institute
pasteur
marcus and maria you may now begin your
presentation
thank you very much for the for the kind
introduction
and welcome to everybody here for the
webinar on the i o biotyper giving some
new insights into microorganisms strain
and serotyping by ftir spectroscopy my
name is marcus meyer i'm the global
product manager
for the irbr chamber and i would like
also to kindly introduce maria pardos de
la gandara she will give the second part
of the presentation with results from
the institute poster
let's get started
so i will give you a very brief
introduction into ftir and io biotyper
product description and then i will turn
to
some
yeah comparison of iobao type and
multibiotyper maybe you know this
product
and give you also some insights into our
news and an outlook in the future
and then i summarize and will pass over
to maria
so first of all a quick introduction and
some questions so
there are some open questions and needs
in hospital hygiene and infection
control and one of them is of course
how can we analyze outbreaks how can
this be performed and is for instance
this an outbreak strain is it one
cluster or is it something different
does
do we have really seen this train
or is it is it something new
and one important question in addition
is how can we
faster and better monitor the
distribution and the transmission of
pathogens
more or less in real time
one important question that is following
then is how can we prevent outbreaks and
how can we implement screening
approaches to be faster and more
preventive
and there are some specific questions
for instance differentiation of
zero groups stereotypes for distant
species for instance it could be
primococci you will hear a little bit
about salmonella
listeria also these are are some
questions that will be answered
ftir principles and some definitions are
made really short so it's it's all about
ir that's infrared light it's an
electromagnetic wave i think you know
this from your time from the study time
or school time that's an electromagnetic
radiation which is defined by the
wavelengths linear frequency
what you will also hear in the next
slide is the wave number wave number is
defined as the wave waves per centimeter
and what's about ft that's fourier
transform that's a kind of quite
complicated mathematical operation which
is increasing the speed and analysis
what are we using here we are using
broca's using in this product absorption
ir technology so there are different
ways how how light infrared light can be
used maybe you have to hurt about
fluorescence
transmission scattering or light can be
reflected but here we use using
absorption of the infrared light
and what is the absorption about the
principle here is that we take a kind of
a snapshot
of a complete of an intact biom of
intake biomolecules in the cell
as you know the structure of a typical
prokaryotic cell made of
water salts and so on but there are
three major very important biomolecules
these are the carbohydrates
many of them on the out outside
first surface of the bacteria and lipids
and proteins and of course other
molecules but these are the three
important ones
and if we look what ftir spectroscopy is
doing in terms of the absorbance you see
on the one scale
you see the absorbance on the other
scale you see the wave number
and there are different regions in the
spectrum where different biomolecules
show some absorption there's on the left
hand side there's the so-called ch
stretching for fatty acids
more in the middle
there's the absorbance for proteins
peptides and on the more on the right
hand side you see they see so-called co
stretching for polysaccharides which are
very important for many
uh differentiating
steps if you look on bacteria
so what is about this
further basics and processing of spectra
first of all the
selectivity of this technology
is very high especially if you look on
the carbohydrate region which is very
important and this allows the
differentiation
of quite closely
related microorganisms and this stands
for this means strain typing maybe you
know strain typing with other
technologies like pfge so some
electricity technologies or some pcr
technologies here we are using the
complete cells and the absorption to
differentiate the strains
and if you look on the spectroid looks
not very
differentiating the raw spectra here are
five different strains with um several
replicates it looks quite similar but
after some mathematical calculation here
the second
derivative of the specific wave number
region again is taken and here you see
that the differences between the
different strains
different colors here are the different
stains and you see the replicates they
fall together but you see difference
between the different strains
so also here it's some mathematical
calculation that is needed all of this
is combined in a real workflow we call
it the ioba type of workflow and this
complete workflow takes
roughly three hours for
roughly 30 samples
the workload starts with harvesting so
we need grown cultures a pure culture
and this culture is taken into a tube we
are suspension so specific
metal cylinders are incorporated and
this is needed to get a good suspension
of the bacterial cells in an ethanolic
solution
then this solution or this um the
suspension is taken and pipetted on the
target plate this is a
standard 96 spot plate where the
infrared light can be uh can be used for
and then it's simply dried on this on
this target plate and it's then inserted
into the instrument and roughly one
minute per spot is the time so this
means one and a half hour for the pure
measurement and for the other sample
prep steps another 30 to one hour
and then the the most interesting step
starts of course because the bioma
informatica analysis that's a very
important step and where most of our
energy is also going to optimize this
for our customers
so we think the ir bar type is a
complete complete solution complete
strain typing solution
it's made of a hardware system a plate
reader spectrometer and this is
optimized for the micro microbial
analysis and we have we are based here
or this technology is based on on the
quads quite huge experience from broker
optics leading technology in terms of ir
spectroscopy
it comes with a software that was
developed by broca diatonic's
microbiology team
and this means that we have algorithms
and visualization tools that are really
optimized for the micro microbiologist
lab
we
generate we provide some standardization
here with the kit solution
so the kit is providing some standards
process controls
lyophilized bacterial cells where a
differentiation must be seen but the
strains are very close to each other and
the suspension vials which i explained
in the slide before are coming also with
the kit to generate really and provide
some standardization here
what's now about the
differentiation or the the the
difference between multibiotype i think
you have heard about this product and
subtyping and the ir bar typo what are
these different products doing so
multibiotyper and subtyping you know
this is based on maldi ms smiley tough
time of flight master mass spectrometry
and this is using peptide and protein
fingerprints a very stable and robust
technology and nowadays the gold
standard in microorganisms
identification on the species level
it comes with a large database of
roughly 4 000 species
and the subtyping module means there's
this allows some subspecies
differentiation for instance for
very closely related species like
listeria
and some intraspecies differentiation is
also possible to detect some resistant
markers for instance for bacteroides
fragilis or for klebsiella
what is the ir biotite in contrast doing
or in combination
this will come later
based on it's more based on self
phenotyping you have intact cells here
and you have the infrared technology
which are described
this is the strain typing methods so
this allows differentiation more on the
isolate level when the identification of
the species is already known
and it can be used for analysis of
outbreaks in real time for hygiene
and infection control for prevention and
fast screening
and it comes also with first databases
of so-called classifiers i will explain
a little bit later
and this can be used for serotyping for
zero grouping for instance for
streptococcus for ligonella
and their first zero grouping o
classifier ocr grouping classifiers for
salmonella and also for listeria
coming to the new features the news of
the io bytebar solution and a little bit
also the outlook what is our focus to
improve further the product and make it
um interesting
so first of all i explained the multibar
type and the ir by typer these
instruments and these solutions the
workflows can be combined now so mbt
malibu tapper can be combined with the
io by type in terms of software and limb
system
we have
largely improved
the gui to make it more easy for our
microbiology customers the usability now
it comes with an easy reporting pdf
report especially for larger data data
sets the performance was improved it's
easier to handle and this is one
important thing here the machine
learning the classifiers which are
already mentioned
this is very important because this is a
learning system where you can put in
known samples and can detect unknown
samples by ready-made classifiers
we have extended the
wave number region so that we can get
now
we can cover also the lipids proteins
the carbohydrate region still remains
very important most of the differences
are in this region
and there are some new very nice
visualization tools really helping our
customers
for instance like a 3d scatter plot and
other tools to visualize visualize and
and display your data
so multi-biochar irb type working
together so this is a
modest slogan here and
it shows that micro microbial
identification species level and strain
typing they're coming closer together as
one solution and i think that's a that's
a very important um thing here to uh to
show
what is about these classifiers that's a
quite new
software tool that we have in the
software since
roughly one year so that offers a really
a new and fast way to to look on
real-time strain typing
and what it's done here so we start with
training sets of known strains known
isolates serotypes of zero groups and
they are they are built into a so-called
statistical model
and this supervised model
can be used for classification of
unknown samples in real time by
comparison to the known strains to this
model and this is based on
artificial neural networks it's a
machine learning algorithm it's a quite
innovative bioinformatics tool to
generate these classifiers and if we
summarize this there's an input the
training data set known samples and then
the algorithm learns
to recognize these known samples and as
an output you can classify unknown
samples from for instance for normal
zero grouping for salmonella for
ligonela and dysteria
and with this i would like to summarize
and conclude
so i hope i've shown that
fdir provides high discrimination power
based on phenotyping of intake cells the
irb type is using fdir is a fast
technique
latest software developments provide
user friendly tools to quickly analyze
outbreaks and detect all the zero groups
zero types by a n
and the connection between the gold
standard for microbial identification
the malibu tapa with the ayurveda by
openstream dimensions for full
characterization of species and strains
so that's quite interesting
and with this i want to thank you
particularly the collaboration partners
our special thanks to dr maria pardos de
la gandara and of course also the bruca
team here on d team the marketing team
technical and application support so
they are very important to to keep the
product here and
to make it really a value for our
customers and
with this i want to thank you of course
for your attention i'm happy to get
later the questions and would like to
pass over
to maria now
thank you marcus so
as it has been said my name is maria
pardos de la gandera i'm the deputy
director of the french national
reference center for e-coli shigella and
mainly for salmonella
in the institute
in paris here in france
the entire bacterial pathogens unit is a
research unit in a secret pastel that
hosts two important centers regarding
salmonella first the french national
reference center in which we monitor
with our main activities to keep the
surveillance of salmonella circulating
among humans in france will receive
about 10 000 samples every year
specimens
we track the emergence of new
stereotypes and new resistance profiles
in this salmonella isolate
and we monitor the increase of number of
cases of human salmonellosis
and
very important also we have to report
immediately to the department of health
any case of typhoid or paratyphoid fever
that identifies as well as any
collective food poisoning which is when
there are two or more patients with
similar symptoms because of eating
suspiciously the same food in a
sort of same period of time more or less
another center that is important in this
unh is the collaborating center for the
world heart organization salmonella
where we provide our expertise in typing
as well as in the systems to
antimicrobial
so just a little introduction because
salmonella has a complicated taxonomy we
are talking about a brand negative road
which can be
anaerobic fusion and it is mobile thanks
to flagella
salmonella is the genus is the name of
the genus that belongs to the
antibacterial ci family and it is
divided into species salmonella interior
which is the
name species affecting humans and
salmonella bon gori which can affect
some animals that is really rare to be
found affecting humans
salmonella enterica is also subdivided
in six sub species by the classical
methods and there are two new subspecies
called by now seven and eight that have
only been identified when using whole
genome sequencing
then all salmonella in derisa and
worries are divided into stereotypes and
we have at the moment has two more than
2500 different stereotypes some of them
as you can see have their own names and
well to summarize we never talk about
salmonella enterica subspecies enterica
stereotype kentucky for example we would
directly say salmonella typhi and this
is how i will talk about it today
otherwise i will take forever
resides in the intestines of infected
animals we say it's a through
anthroponosis because humans will get
infected when eating contaminated food
or through very close contact with
animals and it's not only about
professionals working in farms we also
have to think sometimes about pets
and not only warm heart water sorry warm
blood and animals but
as it starts to be more frequent than
before cold-blooded animals such as
reptiles and in some cases very
important but
they rare in countries where it is not
endemic the human to human contact like
the first history case that was typhoid
mary and that i invite you to
investigate further later on
salmonella for most of sterotypes which
we call minor stereotypes or
non-typhoidal steroids causes a
self-limited gastroenteritis
but there are these few major sterotypes
important ones typhy paradigm a parasite
cb and paratrophy which may cause a
systemic infection called typhoid or
paratyphoid fever which can be
potentially less
okay so traditionally salmonella has
been classified using a first step of
biochemical identification following the
subspecies
regarding a set of of substrates
and followed by the serotyping in which
an agglutination must be done on plate
using over 160 antibodies and following
the white kaufman laminar scheme which
has been the gold standard to identify
certain types for over 90 years you can
see on the top right an extract of this
scheme and the process is usually first
identifying what is called the somatic
antigen that is refined by agglutination
the epitope of the
lipopolysaccharide in the wall of the
cell
and then we follow with the
identification of flagellar antigens
usually two faces phase one and phase
two and with these three antigens
somatic also called o
and the fragellar h one and two we may
have the traditional stereotype to
certify profile
however
since 2018
we have moved in the national center of
reference for salmonella here in france
to whole genome sequencing as the first
intention method for typing so instead
of stereotyping the little
polysaccharide and the flagellins we are
performing mlst i don't know if you will
know about it but i can take some
questions about this later on if needed
which is based on this multi-locus
sequence typing seven genes that are
regarded and the two genes encoding for
the flagellum
cogenome sequencing can also allow us to
do some subtyping that in our case we do
based on the four gene on mlst based on
3000 genoty genes sorry
and finally even if needed we can do
some clustering really detailed
clustering based on single nucleotide
polymorphism
so these new methods are giving us a lot
of information we can know a lot of
things from the bacteria including all
the acquired genes or resistance to
antibiotics
however it requires a longer processing
a long processing compared to the
serotyping and it is unable to respond
to urgent needs as you can see in the
graphs in the bottom we have lost the
ability to give fast answers for
stereotyping that we had in about six to
ten days this is gone and the fastest we
can go with the sequencing at the moment
is about 15 days
so this is when we got interested about
this infrared biodiver as marcus and
other colleagues are telling us the idea
that it can be really fast in detecting
stereotypes or groups at least and
probably outbreaks so we set the test
and the first thing we wanted to do was
a proof of concept and see if it really
could separate strains belonging to
different whole groups that means
somatic so lipopolysaccharides based on
sugars and for this we just took a small
set of samples we took ten strains
passed into replicates each one of them
some of them belonging to the typh
serotype so o9 and some of them belong
into both defemorium and parasites b
which are o4
and we run the basics with the ir
biodiversity i'm not a bioinformatician
i'm a microbiologist a clinical
microbiologist transformation so
just what the machine can give me
without any manipulation and we were
very happy to see already in this then
program application that it has how
tiffy
let's say the o9 group was well
separated from the o4 zero types
the same strengths passed by the tca
analysis on the top right which you can
copyright you can see the
the average spectra for each strategy
generates one average spectrum and in
the bottom you can see the three
duplicates separated and how well the
system managed to separate the o9 this
see to the right in different tones of
thread
and from the old force that are on the
left
this is the same analysis just shown in
this magnificent 3d representations that
i personally like those again with the
typeface the o lines very well to the
right
and the new feature the lda
that seeing it in 2ds doesn't add a lot
of information but if we go to the 3d we
can see also the yellow buttons
representing tcmorion separated from the
different parathyroidis in green and
blue
and again the diffusion nice still
okay these were great results so we went
a bit further and we said let's try to
differentiate several types that share
the same group all these all four same
glosses
but for which we know that the complete
stereotype is different the complete
angiogenic formula is different and for
this we took more samples of typhimurium
and parasite cb
the real parade which is a major
serotype from the parasite phd biotype
java that is considered minor it's a
biotype of paratyphid that causes
gastroenteritis instead of a different
fever so clinically very important this
time a bigger set of samples so 55 and
filling replicates
and again we have quite some promising
results because already with pca
tfemorium is mostly separated to the
left you can see the yellow
dots for holes in the 3d representation
and how the volatility divided by java
which are the green squares
seem to cluster somehow together
compared to the
parathy the real parasite figures that
are outnumbering all the other two
and quite similar results with the lda
we of course we need to go a bit further
and analyze these two outliers from
tissue modern that didn't want to
cluster together with all the rest but
as preliminary results were quite
promising
so why not to god
and we try to compare these two biotypes
the real paradigm causing the
paratyphoid fever which is quite
homogeneous it's usually related only to
mlsp 86 and compare it to
the biotype java which we call it as one
thing but it's actually quite
heterogeneous and it includes many many
different st's so we took several of
them from our collection and we ran a
comparison and
well we need to go further in this
analysis this has been just done in the
end of august and we need to analyze
further but especially looking at the
lda it looks quite promising it could
look like parathy phd are quite grouped
in the center and how the different sps
of the biotech java are a bit more
scattered surround
something that marcus has mentioned and
we also wanted to try are these
classifiers this machine learning so we
did use the
the broker classifier the supervised
model that contains a
well curated collection of different
salmonella cereal groups and we run it
in our isolate in this sample in total
of 65 isolates meaning 195 spectra
because well it runs on every single
spectrum as you can see on the right and
it was quite successful quite quite
it was successful we found the right
group for over 93 percent of the samples
you can see how the system will give you
the o and you can see it in a column
called project on the right and
the machine itself will give you a
confidence that will be differentiated
by colors so green when it's very sure
of itself and red when it's not so
it works very well however there were
some again odd layers like that little t
femorial in the bottom that
went to the old group eight discussed
with the technicians there are things
that we need to figure out because it
could be a problem of
the sample not just quality but if there
are rough strengths that would affect to
the legal polysaccharide of the strain
and then
it would explain why the classifier put
it wrong
the conditions of the preparation are
important which culture media was used
well we know that the classifier by
broker has been optimized for cultures
on blood agar and we did run things both
in miller kingdom and tsa plates
so we might have to work on that
and there are some conditions that can
influence the results like humidity
which was quite viable in our laboratory
those days that we run the samples
and also related to this classifier we
wanted to test the reproducibility for
the system so we just run one same plate
on a friday and the same place just
store that room temperature was run
monday so three days later
and
it we were happy to see how a similar
deviation was observed in all the
spectra you can really visualize
especially on the 3d representation the
plate of friday on the slate of monday
how every isolate has a comparable
deviation
and even better that when we run the lda
which corrects the effect of humidity
every
the six now
copies of the same i select these three
clusters together this means that all
the specs are stored by the machine
and different experiments are comparable
so you can create your own database from
which you can end up creating on and
reaching your own classifiers
so which are the next steps for us first
of all we want to see how well the
the infrared biocyber can identify
outbreaks so we will compare some
sporadic strains from clusters that we
know are epidemiologically related and
to see how well the differentiation is
done
and on the other hand taking advantage
of the vast collection of different
stereotypes gathered by the who
collaborating center we want to test how
well the different servers at least be
all groups are differentiated
so to summarize from our parts the
infrared biocyber was really well able
to differentiate salmonella strains from
the group 9 in this case typhin versus
group 04 represented by some strange
from tfemorium and foreign type 5b
stereotype
it was impressive how the lda was able
to correct the effects of some
acquisition conditions mainly the the
humidity
and how this correction allows really to
compare the spectra from different
brands so as i said you can create your
own database you can improve your own
classifiers so it will be performing
better and better every time you use it
we hope so
our further work anyway we'll need to
analyze those layers that i showed you
here and there and we really want to
know how biotype
one can
discriminate outbreaks from sporadic
isolates we are really thrilled about
this part and we want to test to the
limit this classifier ability to
identify different stereotypes or at
least strength from different old groups
so with this i just want to thank you
for your attention again to thank for
being invited in here and we are
very ready to get any questions or
comments from you
thank you
thank you marcus maria for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started
our first question is
how many samples can be measured by the
ir biotyper per day
yeah that's that's a question for me for
marcus i think
um yeah
as i've explained in my talk uh we have
roughly 30 samples in one and a half
hour measured so this means in principle
you could measure more than 100 samples
a day or let's let's say 150 depends a
little bit on the on your workflow in
the lab but the principle of the
measurements you can you can do a lot of
samples per day let's see let's say
several hundreds
all right thank you
next question
what is the difference between maldi
biotyper and ir biotyper
also this i touched in the presentation
the main difference is here
that the multipart type is giving you
the species identification
ms
gold standard in identification of
microorganisms and the ir biotyper
is a is a tool for strain typing to look
further on differences for instance
based on the on the carbohydrate
or different other biomolecules but we
really make it
try to make it quite clear so species
identity identification
is multibiotyper that's the gold
standard and if you need to look further
the iron bar type as a tool for further
differentiation
to get further differences for instance
on the isolate level
thank you
next question are customers able to
build their own classifiers
yeah that's possible and the software is
is open for this and
this is really also our
intention at brooker that
because the differences and the
the local questions
especially for hydrogen infection are
sometimes so different that we cannot
that we cannot have everything
in our facility to build uh those
classifiers so therefore we keep it open
and the customer itself they can
they can use the classifiers but also
the other tools that are in the software
to build their own database yeah that's
that's possible to make it short
great thank you
next question
what kind of classifiers are included in
the ir bio type or software
yeah i think i mentioned also some um
some examples in the
in in in the presentation so first of
all we have um
i think quite
a big classifier for streptococcus
primarily
holding more than 30 different
stereotypes several groups
we have started and this is therefore of
course very interesting that to see in
maria's talk
that we have started to build first
salmonella oh zero group classifiers
and we have first classifiers for
ligonella to differentiate the major
groups so that's zero group one
that is differentiated to the other two
to 15 i think zero groups
and um we have also first classifier on
on listeria questions
so that's already in our latest software
and we are of course working on more
classifiers which will come in the
future
great thank you
next question
can you use ftir for species level
identification
in principle this was
if we look a little bit in the history
of of species identification and
and strain typing ir ir technology was
used for species identifications in some
cases it's possible but we make it
really
really clear that the species
identification that the maldi is the
gold standard there
and there's some overlap but we
we see really clearly the maldi being
being there uh really ahead of
ir for po species identification so
therefore we we try to
differentiate here very very precisely
great
next question how many salmonella
serotypes can be distinguished by the
new ir biotyper
so that's a little bit um yeah maybe
maria can help me a little bit because i
think that's also an open question
uh i think you know yeah
yeah no that's that's part of what we
want to try with our database especially
from the who collaborating center that
has
normally at least one specimen of each
serial type and we will test the maximum
right now the answer is we don't know we
hope as many as possible the more
different i mean it's more about
differentiating more than purely
identifying you will identify if you
have a good classifier or a good a good
previous database
so
first of all would we try to see how it
differentiates different things and then
how it really identifies which is not
exactly the same intention but it is an
open question we still don't know we
will see
thank you
next question
has the ir biotyper been compared to
whole genome sequencing
how did it perform in comparison
you know that's maybe also a question
for me
um
there are
different uh literatures and and
publications out
uh of course whole genome sequencing
gives you yeah
as the name says the the the complete
genome a lot of information so
we cannot
say that aya bharta is giving always the
same results and has the
the data
death of um
of odeon sequencing but in many cases
and you see it in several publications
especially for some
some gram-negative species for
for instance klebsiella
and also israeliakoli we see a very good
overlap in some of these publications
but whole genome sequencing is giving
you of course the the complete picture
so therefore
the the comparison is not always it's
not a complete overlap but in many cases
with secret
thank you
next question
is the ir biotyper supposed to replace
the mbt biotyper
yeah i think this is uh i've also
addressed this also with the some of the
previous questions
no absolutely not so we see the multibar
type as the gold standard for species
identification and so therefore that's
that's a very clear
yes malibu
will stay
that's the gold standard and the irbi
type is giving an additional orthogonal
technology to do further differentiation
okay
um looks like we have time for one more
question
can we teach the system implement the
database with our own strains
i think this is also for me uh is to
implement own strains in in the database
i think we we had a quite similar
question before
i think yeah you can of course use your
own strains that's the intention
i'm not sure if i
answered completely now maybe you can
repeat the question one one time
um
can we teach the system
implement the database with our own
strengths
can we repeat the system
maybe mario can help
you i'm understanding this is about what
we are discussing the
incrementing the database of the
classifier eventually of this system to
this the answer would be yes so all the
spectra that you read get recorded by
the system and you can choose to use
them or not
as a comparable as a comparison for the
next coming so as i said a bit in my
presentation what we think is that the
more strength you put inside the ones
you trust the ones that were good in
quality you can use them to feed your
classifier so the bigger the better
because it will get more accurate in
future identifications
right
thank you marcus and maria for your
informative presentation
we will now start
um thank you for your time today and
your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor brooker for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye